Sebastian Lege zeigt euch, wie
probiotischer Joghurt und Light-Margarine
billig produziert und sehr teuer verkauft werden - und dabei nicht gerade gesund sind.
Gesundes Essen, Fitness und Wohlbefinden als Verkaufsargument.
Probiotisch wirksam, gut fürs Immunsystem - längst soll Essen nicht mehr nur satt machen.
Es soll uns auch zu einem besseren Leben verhelfen.
SEBASTIAN: "Ihr Wohlfühl-Joghurt"!
Da gehst du gleich morgens zum Kühlschrank, nimmst den Joghurt - zack, bist gleich gut drauf.
Ach, das ist ja auch so eine Fitness-Molke.
Ist etwas schönes, was spannendes.
Und ich stelle jetzt mal so was für
Sie her in super günstig.
Probiotisch klingt nach Wissenschaft und kostet natürlich extra, aber was ist daran besonders?
Aus Milch kann man viel machen,
Käse zum Beispiel.
Etwas Lab zu Milch und schon setzt sich der begehrte Käsebruch ab.
Übrig bleibt Molke.
Nährstoffreich, aber geschmacklich nicht
jedermanns Sache.
In Rohform unverkäuflich. Ganz anders als Molkedrink mit Fruchtgeschmack.
Meistens haben diese Produkte irgendeine Geschmacksrichtung.
Alle Fruchtvarianten, Vanille und Co.
Heute haben wir gesagt:
Wir machen Maracuja.
Damit wir ein schönes Mundgefühl erhalten: ein bisschen Binder.
Einen guten Schuss Süßstoff.
Magermilchpulver. Minimal.
Fertig ist Leges Maracuja-Molkedrink.
Und der wird jetzt probiotisch aufgehübscht mit
lebenden Milchsäurebakterien.
Probiotische Bakterien. Ein kleines Tröpfchen dieser Wunderzutat - das reicht schon!
Zum Glück sind die Milchsäurebakterien
so harmlos wie preiswert.
Den schnöden Molkedrink verwandeln sie in ein probiotisches Getränk, das sich teuer verkaufen lässt
Zum Wohl! Auf ein gesundes Leben!
Das schmeckt richtig gut.
Fruchtig, schön cremig durch den Binder.
Die probiotischen Bakterien sind schon am Kribbeln.
Ich würde mal sagen: Turnschuhe an,
ich gehe eine Runde joggen!
Aber bringt der Fitnessdrink wirklich
zusätzliche Fitness?
Was ist dran an den Wellness- und Vital-Versprechen, mit denen so viele Produkte werben?
Schaut man genauer hin, sind Zweifel angebracht.
Selbst wenn ein Becher eine Milliarde
Bakterien enthält und man wohlwollend
annimmt, dass ein Zehntel davon noch
lebend im Darm ankommt, sind das
trotzdem nur 0,0001 Prozent dessen, was
dort sowieso schon vorhanden ist.
Das ist so, als würde man im Berliner Grunewald einen einzigen neuen Baum pflanzen.
Gut gedacht, aber ohne großen Effekt.
Ob probiotische Joghurts jetzt gesünder
sind als normale Joghurts, da hat die
Wissenschaft den letzten Spruch noch
nicht gesprochen und die Tendenz geht so: es sind Joghurts.
Kein Wunder, denn auch jeder normaler
Naturjoghurt enthält lebende Bakterien.
Probiotische Zusätze schaden nicht, aber
ob sie es wirklich besser machen...?
Wissenschaftlich jedenfalls ist das
letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen.
Wir bieten an: einen Naturjoghurt, einen
mit probiotischen Bakterien und einen
mit extra Vitaminen. Wofür würden sich
die Berliner entscheiden?
Ich habe meistens Naturjoghurt und tue
mir dann eben meine
Früchte eben rein oder je nachdem was
ich rein haben möchte.
Jeder soll einen angemessenen
Preis aufschreiben. für Naturjoghurt
würden unsere Tester im schnitt 70 bis
80 Cent pro Becher ausgeben.
Deutlich mehr als er in Wirklichkeit
kostet.
Für Bakterien draufzahlen? Nicht mit den Berlinern!
70 bis 80 Cent - genau wie beim Naturjoghurt ist auch schon großzügig gerechnet.
Für zusätzliche Vitamine sind unsere
Testpersonen dagegen durchaus bereit,
mehr zu zahlen.
Der gute Ruf der Vitamine als Gesundmacher zeigt Wirkung.
Der wäre mir jetzt mehr wert, weil da Vitamine drin sind, die mir gut tun.
Also Vitamin C oder Vitamin B12
Das wären dann gleich 12 Vitamine auf einmal und da würde ich mehr ausgeben.
Keine Frage: Ohne Vitamine können wir nicht überleben.
Doch nirgends in Deutschland herrscht heute noch Vitaminmangel.
Wer gesund ist und sich einigermaßen
ausgewogen ernährt, braucht keine
Vitaminzusätze oder Pillen.
Vor allem Eltern sollten beim Wort
Vitam in auf Packungen lieber stutzig werden.
Unser experte entdeckt beim genauen
Hinsehen hinter der gesunden Fassade
jede Menge süße Kalorienbomben, die
genau das Gegenteil von ausgewogener
Ernährung sind.
Sieht aus wie ein Kinderprodukt.
Multivitamin, Erfrischungsgetränk,
12 Prozent Frucht aus sechs Früchten.
Da haben sie aber mal richtig
reingehauen, oder?
Und ganz wichtig: mit Zusatz von Vitaminen.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ich meine, Leute - echt. Ein Kinderprodukt, das aus Wasser und Zucker besteht?!
Also da sind so Sachen... Kinder werden damit animiert
viel zu viel Zucker zu sich zu nehmen,
obwohl es für die wirklich nicht gut ist.
Wir wissen's alle.
In so einem Tütchen stecken umgerechnet sechs Stück Würfelzucker.
Und die Vitamine? dann doch lieber einen Apfel!
Achtet ihr auf Zusätze in Milchprodukten?
Oder lasst ihr die die getrost beiseite?
Sagt es uns in den Kommentaren!
Aber wie sieht es nun mit Light Produkten aus?
Was steckt hier eigentlich drin?
Light-Produkte! Längst ein Klassiker,
denn viele Deutsche kämpfen mit
den Pfunden und hoffen auf einen Genuss
ohne Reue.
Die Industrie weiß das und bietet so gut
wie alles auch in einer Leicht-Variante an,
die weniger Kalorien, weniger zucker
oder weniger Fett enthält.
Er lässt alles wölkchenleicht
erscheinen - der Light-Trick!
Wie man es schafft, dem Essen die
Kalorien auszutreiben, wird Sebastian
Lege jetzt zeigen, bei der Mutter aller
Diätprodukte, der Light-Margarine.
Für unsere Light-Margarine brauchen wir
folgende Zutaten: Pflanzenöl, Palmfett
Milchpulver, Mono- und Diglyceride,
Vitamin E, Vitamin D, Betacarotin, Vitamin A.
Und was wäre eine Light-Margarine ohne Wasser?
Denn davon brauchen wir einiges.
Palmfett und Bindemittel sorgen dafür
dass die Margarine schön fest und streichzart wird.
Vitamine sind gut fürs
Image. Aroma und Farben sollen Geschmack
und Aussehen von Butter imitieren.
Dank Lecithin als Emulgator wird das
Wasser restlos gebunden.
So, die Emulsionist geglückt. Das muss jetzt nur noch ein paar Stunden in den Kühlschrank
und dann können wir uns ganz genüsslich ein Brot damit streichen.
Dis auf die etwas knallig geratene Farbe
ist die selbstgemachte Light-Margarine
kaum von einer normalen zu unterscheiden.
40 Prozent Fett, der Rest Wasser - dafür
steht sie ganz gut da.
Probieren wir das Ganze mal!
Klassisch auf der Scheibe Brot.
Dank Chemie hat Lege den Fettgehalt von 80 auf 40 Prozent geschrumpft.
Aber wie schmeckt die Margarine für die schlanke Linie?
Das schmeckt wirklich komisch.
Das wäre für mich überhaupt gar keine Alternative.
Egal ob Zucker oder Fett - sobald sie einen Faktor um 30 Prozent reduzieren,
dürfen Hersteller ihr Produkt
als Light bewernen.
Aber wie viel Kalorien spart man damit
wirklich?
Die Zwillinge Sandra und Diana Miller
machen für uns den Test.
Einen Tag lang wird Sandra nur Light Produkte essen, ihre Schwester ernährt sich ganz normal.
Wie groß wird die Kalorienersparnis am
Ende sein?
Los geht's mit dem Frühstück: Sandra darf beim fettarmen Joghurt und
zuckerreduzierte Müsli nach Lust und
Laune zulangen.
Man fühlt sich irgendwie schon so ein
bisserl besser einfach.
Ich denke jetzt: Ich kann jetzt ein Müsli
essen mit Joghurt und allem drum und dran
aber trotzdem tue ich mir was gutes.
Liegt sie nach dem fettarmen Joghurt und Light-Müsli wirklich vorn?
Pro 100 Gramm gerechnet ist der
Unterschied beim Müsli praktisch 0.
406 Kilokalorien im Vergleich zu 398 beim
Light-Produkt.
Einschließlich des fettarmen Joghurt, spart die Portion Müsli immerhin 76 Kilokalorien.
Beim Mittagessen bringt das
Fertiggericht von Weight Watchers mit
360 Kalorien zwar einen deutlichen
Vorteil im Vergleich zum Standardgericht mit 523.
Beim Salatdressing aber
schnappt dann die erste Light-Falle zu.
Sandra greift zum Joghurtdressing
anstatt zum Klassiker aus Essig und Öl.
Dabei hat der nur 84 Kalorien und das
vermeintlich leichte Joghurtdressing 327
und damit viermal so viel!
Damit schrumpft der Light-Vorteil auf
gerade mal 20 Kalorien zusammen.
Beim Nachtisch hat Sandras Wölkchenpudding nur deshalb weniger Kalorien, weil ihre Portion kleiner ist.
Dianas Schokodessert hat über 200 Kalorien aber auch 200 Gramm.
Der Light-Pudding 116 Kalorien bei
125 Gramm.
Wer deshalb noch einen zweiten Becher
isst, der ist in die nächste Light-Falle getappt.
Beim Abendbrot spart Sandra durch Light-Margarine und Käse gegenüber Dianas 444 Kalorien wieder einiges ein.
370! Das gibt einen buchstäblich leichten Vorteil.
Bei Chips droht die dritte Light-Falle.
Fett wird durch andere Nährstoffe ersetzt, die fast ebenso viele Kalorien haben.
Die Tagesbilanz fällt ernüchternd aus:
Nur 147 Kalorien - nicht mal zehn Prozent -
hat Sandra mit Light Produkten gespart
Dann kann ich eigentlich komplett nach
meinem Geschmack gehen!
Was mir wirklich besser tut oder gefällt.
Brauch' mir eigentlich keine Sorgen machen über "Light oder nicht Light".
Fazit: Wer abnehmen will, sollte das nicht nur durch Light-Produkte versuchen.
Weniger Fett oder Zucker bedeutet nämlich nicht automatisch auch weniger Kalorien.
Versucht ihr Zucker oder Fett zu
reduzieren?
Welche Tricks habt ihr da auf Lager?
Teilt es mit uns in den
Kommentaren!
Und wo es die besten Lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt, zeigen wir
euch auf unserem Kanal ZDFbesseresser.